entre los aplausos de sus simpatizantes
xiomara castró prestó juramento este
jueves en un evento multitudinario
dentro del estadio nacional de
tegucigalpa
prometo
ser bien la repubblica tras juramentar
donde la jueza carla ribera el
presidente del parlamento luis redondo
le colocó la banda presidencial
convirtiéndola en la primera presidenta
de honduras un hecho histórico según la
nueva encargada
han tenido que pasar
200 años
desde que se proclamó
nuestra independencia
la mandataria tendrá una gran carga en
las espaldas en su discurso recalcó la
importancia de luchar contra la
corrupción y dijo que el saldo de la
deuda externa del país subió al 319 por
ciento desde 2009 también recordó que
los niveles de pobreza alcanzan al 70%
de la población para quienes anunció
subsidios que más
donde familias que viven en pobreza
y consumen
menos de 150 kilowatts por mes
[Música]
a la nueva presidenta también se
comprometió a proteger el medio ambiente
no más permisos de minas abierta o
explotación de nuestros minerales de la
mano de su esposo el depuesto ex
presidente manuel zelaya castro inicia
un mandato previsto para cuatro años
donde la ruptura interna de su propio
partido se presenta como el primer gran
obstáculo